[Music]
if you've been driving around the u.s
this week there's a chance you've
overtaken a tesla owner who was driving
really carefully
that's because tesla is preparing to
offer more users access to parts of its
full self-driving software that were
previously off limits see while people
who have paid for fsd have been able to
use some of the driver assistance tools
one feature auto steer on city streets
has been fenced off
but now oh yeah
here it is limited early access full
self-driving beta but there's a catch in
order to use this new city driving
feature tesla is making its vehicle
owners demonstrate that they are safe
drivers that's led to some tesla owners
taking their cars out for well less of a
spin and more of a gentle cruise as they
try to score well on tesla's safety test
to gain access to that fsd beta i
promise i will be a very good boy so
what does this safety test entail and
why is tesla making its vehicle owners
demonstrate that they're safe drivers in
the first place well fasten your seat
belt and check that rear mirror i'll
explain
okay first we need to clear something up
because although this software is called
full self-driving the car cannot fully
drive all by itself that's the beta does
not make my car autonomous right sure
the suite of features offers tesla
owners some advanced driver assistance
tools like automated lane changing auto
park and systems that help you drive on
a highway but even tester itself says
the currently enabled autopilot and full
self-driving features do not make the
vehicle autonomous but musk has said he
has plans to enable all modern teslas to
potentially be autonomous and the fsd is
part of the path towards autonomous
driving all tesla cars being produced
right now have everything necessary for
full self-driving around 360 000 people
have paid a lump sum of up to ten
thousand dollars to have access to fsd
features tesla also gives users the
option to subscribe for up to two
hundred dollars per month um tesla has
been rolling out features one by one
autosteer on city streets has remained
the exclusive domain of a handful of
testers until now on the 24th of
september musk tweeted fsd beta request
button goes live tonight but when users
tap that request button they weren't
immediately given access you are
enrolled for that full self-driving beta
cube now
oh yeah
instead they were entered into a queue
and musk said they would only be granted
access if driving behavior is good for
seven days
behavior is monitored using tesla's
safety score beta data is sent to tesla
from the vehicle to monitor things like
potential collisions hard braking
aggressive turning and unsafe following
it takes all of these factors and gives
you a score based on your driving and
helpfully it even tells you where you
went wrong kind of like having your mum
in the back of the car it's resulted in
quite a few people driving very
carefully to try and gain that score so
how good do you need to be to access the
beta well it's unclear musk has tweeted
that they plan on onboarding around 1
000 people per day starting with the
very safest drivers and then working
their way down
but we don't know at what level they'll
stop
but you may be wondering why tesla is
asking its drivers to prove they're safe
in order to gain access to software that
drives on their behalf well part of the
reason could be down to that name full
self-driving see my colleague rebecca
elliott spoke to the head of the ntsb
who called tesla's use of the term full
self-driving misleading and
irresponsible and added that people pay
more attention to marketing than to
warnings in car manuals with an ongoing
nutser investigation into its less
advanced autopilot system the last thing
tesla needs right now is any additional
crashes where its driver assist software
could be called into question
but let's be real here what tesla have
managed to do is make some of its
vehicle owners drive a little bit safer
if only for a week and given how many
crashes there are on us roads each year
that can't be a bad thing
hey rebecca elliot actually spoke to my
colleague alexander hops for a separate
video on this and i've left a link to
that video below and as always if you're
interested in the future of how we might
be getting from a to b then don't forget
to subscribe catch you later
[Music]